hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
heilpan show we are live and today we
have a very interesting conversation
we're going to be talking about privacy
free speech and information on the
internet so joining me on the show today
is one of the Genesis Developers for
tominet a new alternative internet that
is doing amazing things in the world of
decentralization freedom of speech and
information which is what we so
desperately need in this world now
before I bring on my guest please don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe if you support this kind of
content as I'm going to be bringing you
a lot more of it so let's welcome techno
techno welcome to the stream how are you
so excited to have you here now I think
the most important thing to do is
explain why you are wearing a mask
um as opposed to me who isn't wearing a
mask so exactly why you're anonymous um
and I believe the rest of your team are
Anonymous as well
yeah most of us are anonymous
[Music]
the first reason is that some of us are
coming from countries
where freedom of speech and freedom to
access information
is actually kind of problematic
the kind of governments that are
censoring information
and blocking websites blocking Wikipedia
blocking other websites uh and
developing a tool that allows this
information to become accessible
is potentially dangerous okay so in
order to respect
some of our other team leaders and to
respect the the
right to be a a safe
we decided that all of us are relating
to them and not by the way one of us is
not Anonymous but the rest of us is so
that's one reason second reason is
actually an ideology
a ideological reason
and
it goes like this so basically we wanted
the
the people to judge this project based
on the technology and the idea and the
implementation and the user experience
we didn't want
to be judged by other things like the
identity of the people or the identity
of the developers
uh just like when we when we initially
wrote
the white page of the Bitcoin
then we think that Satoshi is anonymous
by Design we don't think it was we don't
think it was Chinese or we had some
issues
we simply think that he understood that
for people to judge their idea based on
the idea it needed to be anonymous if it
wasn't Anonymous maybe his neighbors
maybe he's a school teacher maybe
someone that doesn't like him would have
this this project and then damaging and
I'm not sure Wheatland would have become
Bitcoin so if you want to be pure
if you want to be clean
it's better to be judged by your actions
and not by other things so so from those
two those are the two main reasons the
that we decided to be like that and then
the personas that we're using
would be also
in the future to ensure the continuity
of this project then the team would be
replaced
and we'll talk about this later but the
team would be replaced and we need to
make sure that people are judging the
team based on the actions and not based
on something else
I think it's so crazy how in a world
where we're trying to promote free
speech and you know ultimately human
rights we have to protect our identities
because it's just that dangerous you
know Ross Albrecht is a great example of
this all he did was create you know a
free market for people to transact and
he has to now serve two life sentences
um so I understand the importance of um
anonymity and privacy in everything that
you're doing so let's address and
discuss in detail what the current issue
is in society which you're creating a
solution for what are the problems with
mainstream media whether it's the BBC
Sky News whether it's big tech companies
that have this Monopoly on information
what is the key issue that you guys are
trying to solve
yeah so let's go to the basics and start
with the infrastructure of the internet
and understand why it became like that
so
the the the the the
situation today
is that as you know if you say your
opinion and you're too aggressive and
blunt about it you're risking your
freedom yes even in even in
sophisticated Western countries you're
risking your freedom you know uh I would
let's say like this regarding Andrew
Tate
I'm not sure let's say if he wasn't
educate I'm not sure he was arrested
right now uh and this is just one
example there's so many examples in
China
we hear more and more about people that
Express their political opinion and then
mysteriously disappeared
uh so for some reason for some people
it's risking the lives
for some people it's risking their
freedom for some people it's risking the
reputation you know sometimes when you
say what you what you believe in you can
be judged in in publicly shamed by other
people
and that's crazy because we used to
think that the
I don't want to get too political left
and right but I think that most of us
believe the that we need to be liberal
that we need to be and when I say
literal I mean to support and speech yes
the real exactly the real version of
liberal even if you say things that I
don't agree with I will fight for your
right to say it and I'm not gonna shut
your mouth or or sanction you or fight
you and that's a big problem now let's
go back to the technology and understand
what is the problem so the the problem
was that when the internet was
structured the architecture of it made
that the power goes to it then to an
administrator
right now most of people doesn't know
that but the internet is fully
controlled by America
fully controlled by America I mean the
infrastructure of the internet the the
the domain name systems there are
officially it's controlled by 13
entities which is a joke but it sits in
Los Angeles which means initially you
know it's controlled by America now also
different governments can easily block
websites through blocking the right
piece
so it's extremely easy for them just
what is the idea of these websites and
boom no more material for you and the
what we wanted to do we looked at the
the tall project
which is the enabler of the darkness
and we saw that they've done very
interesting things in terms of
encryption
but they lost something else so they
have they are completely uncensored but
the second but they have two main issues
instead of becoming the freenet
which all of us would have been using it
became the darkness
and the two major problems that they had
is
yes they were encrypted but they add a
serious UI issue so instead of simple
domains you have long encrypted
addresses the onion addresses
and then also the fact that it wasn't
moderated
by anyone
it's also a minus because you can see
Bad actors like Terror organizations or
pedophiles taking advantage of this
system and then it becomes a place you
don't want to go in so what we've done
we took a lot of the encryption
and we built something that is a
completely alternative internet Network
which is controlled by the community
it's owned and controlled by the users
so the users can block those websites
which the power should be at the hands
of the people and not in the ends of
some dictators
I think that's such an important point
to make because people often get really
concerned that if you have a platform
which isn't um you know regulated by one
centralized Authority a CEO whatever it
is they feel that um it will encourage
Bad actors like like you said but having
that community that has the ability to
um you know uh sift through the Bad
actors I I think makes a lot of sense
and you know we talk about
um your right to say it you're allowed
to say what you want
um it doesn't matter if it offends me
um you have a right to offend me but I
want to focus on what the importance of
that is like what is the problem with
surveillance and and the issue with
censoring speech and information and
just as an example you know we're
looking at what happened with covert
over the last three years for me it blew
my mind how you know they were censoring
um people who ask questions about the
vaccine and now that it's coming out
that actually these people were correct
so let us go down that rabbit hole and
understand the problem with um
censorship
yeah you know that's a great example
that you gave
when people criticize the process
media portrayed them is the crazy people
they will
like
the whole image of those people became
the crazy anarchist
and you know you say they were right but
even if they were wrong they are still
entitled to express their opinion or to
ask questions
and
that's what is that war is me and not
only me it was many many people
across the world today the media is
fully fully fully controlled by a
certain agenda
and brainwash and taking the you know
they they use this stage
to brainwash so many people
uh to the point that you are being
shamed if you're expressing a different
opinion sometimes you know you you are
one of the brave people
I know you have some community that are
around you and supporting you but I know
you have your haters I know you have
your May sales
of course of course because you are real
you are saying your opinion and some
people if you're not politically correct
they're jumping all over you because
you're not allowed to express a
different opinion true liberalism
is also to express opinion against
those that uh considered to be the
Liberals so we think that the only way
to really solve this
is to re redesign the system
redesign the system
if you maneuver it a bit change it a bit
then in the long term you can have a
better result
so we are
rebuilding the internet we are building
we are rebuilding the domain name system
we are rebuilding the encryption we are
rebuilding the browser we are rebuilding
the payment system we're rebuilding the
entire ecosystem one of the things that
I really liked about this project when I
joined it
uh I was that it's trying to do to the
internet what Bitcoin did to money
and you know and in order to achieve
this it takes time Bitcoin is around for
40 meals and still it's not even a tenth
of the potential that it has so it takes
time
but we have time and we want to do
something meaningful and if we want our
kids
to enjoy a real free wall
and the ability to access information
into a free speech and to express and
learn then we need to build it in a way
that the governments and the giant
corporations doesn't have the power to
stop us from learning or from stop us to
speak
and and and this was the main thing that
the Tommy was incorporated
surrounding this
and this is how we do this
and I think it couldn't come at a better
time really um I feel like censorship is
just increasing you know I've personally
had a lot of my videos censored and um
you know you make an important point
when you say that people do judge you
based on your opinions um you know I
have people that get very upset with me
and people you know may choose to not
want to work with me because of things
that I say but you know I share the same
opinion as you it's like well ultimately
I just want to live in a free world
where everybody has access to
um free information and can then decide
to navigate their lives accordingly
without um you know the threat of an
authority and violence from above or
whatever it is um so why in your opinion
is decentralization
and um anonymity so important to
everyone that uses the internet and
modern technology and what would you say
some of the issues would be that I might
face when using um essentialized
software with no privacy or at least
anonymity you know like Twitter or
YouTube
yeah so first of all you know the the
internet is not free the internet cost
you can pay with your money or you can
pay with your data but it's not free now
today
99 of us are paying with our data
which I think
most of us don't understand the
problematics of this it's a huge huge
problem you can speak with your friend
about a vacation in in London and then
immediately go to Instagram or Facebook
and boom you have an advertisement about
education it's crazy oh it's amazing yes
it's amazing today
when these people
the ads of the biggest Tech
organizations in the world
with this data they can easily easily
control the public opinion
and
and take you to whatever they want to
promote their agendas their interests
you're like a blind Chief you don't even
understand it you that you are because
of the sophistication of these systems
and if you're awoke
and you're awake
and you're trying to awake the other
people you'll consider this crazy you
can be censored out of Instagram out of
freedom and shut your voice
if the former president of America got
blocked
from all of the social media stages then
who are we to speak right
so I think it's it's so important and
crucial
to build the infrastructure in a way and
it's not going to take a day for sure
not it's not something it's gonna take
time but we're planting the seeds
to build a decentralized internet
a kind of internet that you don't need
to pay with your data
by the way I prefer to pay money I
prefer to pay money and not to pay you
know what I would rather pay money
to keep my privacy and my anonymity and
my data away from those guys
don't worry if they give you the the
content for free
it means that they're making more money
from your data okay and and and you are
becoming the product there's no such
thing free product if the product is
free you are the product
and I think that we redesigning it in a
way that offer people even to pay maybe
even to pay on the internet because you
know people like you Leia you are
creating valuable content
valuable content
but the ways to monetize this content is
a problem and you know it it's a problem
what if there was an easy way that
people would simply in in an indirect
way
all this content because it's valuable
right
similar to the things that you can see
like in Spotify like in Spotify I don't
pay to listen to a song
I'll pay to Spotify
but then when I listen to a specific
song Spotify pays the musician what if
there was something in this kind of
business model that protects your
privacy gives you the power but at the
same time it allows the content creators
to monetize I think that in order to
build this infrastructure we need to
build everything from grounds up because
otherwise the governments can dislike it
the giant corporations can dislike it
and they can just simply stop you
because they don't like it you'll take
you're moving their cheese you're taking
away their towel
so this we we are now in the very
beginning in the very
uh
start of this building this building
blocks in order that in few years we
will have an ecosystem
that will allow you to access
information without government's
interference it will allow content
creators like yourself to monetize it
without stealing my data and I think in
general it's just a better internet it
will take time
but it should be there
and you know I want to go back a little
bit on what you said about
um the ads you know you can be having a
conversation one day and then suddenly
Instagram shows you an ad and I think at
this stage a lot of people might
consider this a good thing you know
because it helps move life forward and
like in this efficient way but nobody
seems to um understand the dangers of
this technology long term and how it can
be used to you know manipulate society
and push certain agendas long term
um and so that's why I'm just I'm so
excited about the idea of an alternative
internet
um pushing forward for that and I guess
I'd like to understand some of the
technical aspects that Tommy is creating
we spoke actually a month ago in my
Twitter spaces about the Tommy browser
itself which obviously is the web
browser but can you talk about the tdns
Tommy net and how all of this comes
together to create this alternative
decentralized ecosystem
yeah sure sure so
there are eight different team leaders
in the project there's almost 100 people
involved
in in different places of the world it's
truly a decentralized project and I said
we need to build different building
blocks so one of this is the pdms the
tdns is like you can call it like the
GoDaddy of the Tommy net okay it's where
you go you can buy domains it's a
parallel universe so it's extremely cool
you can buy a short.com domains uh very
cheap right now it's like the beginning
of the new internet so so things like
this and the tdns is in test net mode
right now so you can go and play around
with that and test it but it's not yet
live it will be live soon but this is
like the domains it sits on the
blockchain so governments cannot block
it
and that's extremely important and the
TDMs supports normal IPS but also
encrypted onion IPS
which which is unblockable so the tdns
is one important building block then
obviously
we have our browser
we've opened it eventually the browsers
like Chrome and Firefox uh Safari and
the others will support its dominant but
we are in the very beginning and we
decided to build this ecosystem in a
self-sustained way we don't want to be
dependent on other projects so then
suddenly Google decides to block us and
boom there's no motor in it so we
developed our own browser as well and
this browser allows you to serve the web
and enjoy both the normal internet and
also the decentralized internet so we
have our browser then we have our
digital payment system because in an
alternative internet you need to have
also a payment system and it's a very
cool payment system that you are
developing I think I will I will give
two minutes about this because I think
we are the team over there is also
solving the problem and it's the Privacy
problem so there's anonymity and there's
privacy it's not necessarily the same
thing meaning anonymity you can be
anonymous just like I am right now with
you but if I'm giving you my wallet
address even though I'm Anonymous and
you don't know who I am you can still go
and see my e-story and you can see my
transactions you can see my balance
which is not not like what we used to if
we want people to really replace
a a the financial system then you need
to give also the benefits like when I go
to the supermarket I mean I pay with my
credit card
then the the the seller cannot see uh
what I had in the past what I have right
now it's just and I can and I can see is
so we are developing a privacy level on
top of ethereum which could be an
enormous project by itself by the way
it's amazing to give privacy to ethereum
based tokens it's extremely cool
so the Tommy payment the the Tommy pay
digital payment system is also a very
important part of this ecosystem
then we have two more parts
we have our own nodes
we have a long node and these nodes
how basically allowing us to encrypt the
information and in the future we will
also allow it to be
serving as a proxies as vpns maybe if we
decide to do a blockchain it could be
also a consensus support system but
but this is our nodes and then we have
the Dao the Dao that is probably the
most important part
the Dow manages today a bit more than 12
million dollars
it's growing
and this dial controls the entire
ecosystem so as I mentioned before the
dark and block websites
the block the dial
is an Unchained out
it looks like there's a committee that
we vote and then they go and execute
because this is a this is a point of
failure
did someone this committee can can is
actually
controlling everything so we don't we
didn't want committee to we didn't want
the certain people to control everything
right so we did we developed an
Unchained out
and this on chain has codes that enforce
themselves the doubt is so decentralized
that it isn't even allow
to fire us it can kick me out it can it
can replace the entire team
the dog can control the circulation of
the tokens it can control the issuance
it can control the rewards that the team
is getting increasing them decreasing
them the Dow controls everything execute
the power should be in the ends of the
users
I I think that I think that's amazing um
because not enough
um
you know CEOs and people in charge um
are ever held accountable for their
actions so it's it's very I think it's
very important that you know team
leaders so to speak
um can actually be held accountable and
if somebody doesn't like if the Dow
doesn't like the direction that it's
going then they can fire their team
leaders that's so powerful that's so
important and that really does of course
you know help um solidify the um the
decentralization of it and you know
crypto and blockchain technology is
obviously the future and we see so many
projects crying trying to create the
next big thing claiming to be
decentralized and for the people in the
spirit of crypto and self-sovereignty
you know and all of that but I want to
sort of understand a little bit more I
know we have touched on this but I want
to get more detail on how the Tommy
ecosystem actually facilitates this new
decentralized infrastructure of
blockchain Technology
you know you mentioned other projects I
gotta tell you you know so the team
all of us the mean the minimum uh is
like five six years in the in the
industry okay so all of us are veterans
and
we love this industry we love the
potential we believe in the ideology of
it
but at the same time I gotta tell I
gotta I gotta admit
95 of the project
are damaging
damaging the industry
damaging the perception of the industry
the image of the industry uh
I I I kind of ate mean tokens I'm sorry
I think it's damaged I hate them too
yeah I agree with you so so
I gotta say over here when we built Domi
we we used our own money
we used our own experience and time and
and and first of all in the first deal
we didn't speak with anyone we didn't go
live we didn't do anything we just
developed and code code code and
developed those projects and products
and now when we just we we only launched
the token like 40 days ago
and we really like the results so far
you so the community is becoming bigger
and bigger token went from like 16 70
cents to like 10x and but but that's not
what is important what is important is
to bring a utility I always say uh or we
always say that the big success of Tommy
is not a stormy
becomes a top 25 coin Market card
project which I'm sure it will be
it's not if the token does 100x which I
I believe it will but but this is not
the success the success would be if
millions of users that doesn't know what
is blockchain that doesn't care about
crypto
using Tommy because of the benefits of
Tommy and we think it is what makes it
so so special we think that we we we we
we will get there we are soon going to
announce a partnership with a mega brand
one of the biggest brands of the world
yeah it's very exciting and it's going
to happen soon and they are just the
first ones to join the terminate and we
think that content is the key in the end
with all the restrictive technology
content was and will be the king always
always
and if we're not going to bring content
into the dominant then users are not
going to use it if we are going to bring
content to the dominant users will come
in and use it and then they will also
enjoy the benefits we spoke about before
but people are egoistic
creatures and they're looking for
immediate immediate respond and
immediate benefit and this is why we
we're going to invest tens of millions
of dollars into content
so I think this is a big difference
between us and other projects our
experience the fact that we put our own
money and the fact that we're
understanding the content is the key and
the non-blockchain people non-blocking
users are the true key
to make this a success
yeah you make a really interesting point
people always
um look at well I I always um measure
mass adoption by understanding whether
people know what they're using so you
know if they don't realize that they're
using blockchain technology and they're
just using something because they need
it because the utility is just that good
that's success and that's adoption um
and you know it's really interesting
because when I first heard about you
guys one of the things that really
struck me was the fact that you um are
providing internet access to people all
over the world so the two biggest
countries I know that have the highest
amount of surveillance and control over
um speech and information are of course
China and North Korea so how does Tommy
provide a solution to people in those
types of countries who cannot access the
internet
yes so we we increase the we encrypt the
IP so basically any website can use the
onion protocol to encrypt this IP and
then take this a new address and put it
in the pdns which support it support
this encryption using our own blockchain
based domain name system and then
the combination of two of them with the
browser actually gives people even in
these places that you mentioned access
to to websites that
have been blocked until now by the way I
think North Korea is a bit different
because over there they it's like a
black box they don't give any access
outside but China China does give you
China two three Arab countries
do give you access to websites but they
censor some of them so
so this is something that we can solve
North Korea it's a problem that I think
will be solvable only when Elon musks a
internet
will be
full space achievable to them because in
the end there's a you need to have the
data type
so I think that when masks figure this
out and I think you did but yes of
Regulation issues but when it gives the
people of North Korea the ability to
connect to his internet then we can give
them access to all of the places that
the government doesn't want
okay that makes a lot of sense
um yeah North Korea is an interesting
one but but it's good to know that you
know it's there's there is hope and when
more uh people work together who all
have a similar Vision we're actually
able to bring internet free information
free speech to all these people you know
whether it's you know Tommy working with
Elon Musk and many different many
different people but what is interesting
actually is I receive a lot of messages
from projects claiming to be
decentralized but after I do a little
bit of research um into the background
um I find out that their servers are
actually centralized because they're
running on Amazon web servers or Google
data information centers so my question
is how is the Tommy net ecosystem
um truly decentralized you know in a way
that Bitcoin is with miners all around
the world
yeah that's a great question so so do
things we got in this so
not naming names I don't want to shame
anyone but I can tell you that we are
speaking with the biggest crypto
projects and we see there's certain
weaknesses
that they didn't thought about when they
started the the project that makes them
actually completely centralized uh I'll
give you an example even a project that
the entire team
is not Anonymous and it sits in America
you can develop whatever you want in the
end
if most of your nodes are in America yes
and the team is in America or you know I
say America but it doesn't matter in a
certain country
then this country can simply come take
the team
and if there's no mechanism that gives
the control
to other people
then you'll basically centralized uh
also I can tell you that a lot of the
projects as legal advisors in their
teams that they are actually centralized
and controlling everything because they
make everyone scared and they tell you
listen privacy oh my God no because the
American
money laundering enforcement they will
say anonymity and privacy is not good so
now let's do kyc let's do kyc those are
big issues so we see more and more like
this so I can tell you that
we didn't solve everything but we did
solve everything that we thought
whether we can think about before like
for example the fact that we are in
eight different countries is by Design
the fact that we are Anonymous is by
Design the fact that we gave the Dow the
power to replace us is just for reasons
like this to ensure the continuity of
this project whether it's because
someone stopped us
go whether it's because we simply want
this project to be exist in a thousand
years and so far no one invented any way
for us to do that maybe musk is working
on this but so far there's no solution
so we gave this power to them then you
mentioned Amazon Cloud yes I don't know
between Amazon Cloud Microsoft cloud and
Google Cloud you can safely say that 95
of the projects are using their services
yes now I think that there's two
solutions for this one solution is to
encrypt the data to encrypt the
information and then even they don't
know how to stop it because they don't
know what they're storing that's one
thing but the better thing would be to
use a clouds decentralized clouds like
file coin like flux those other anchor
the the few of them
the the solutions are not
is is a
as good and advanced as Amazon is right
now okay
but but but it's getting there it's
getting low so so we are working with
these companies in order to either
encrypt the data or either a store it
and host it on a decentralized
technology
yeah I understand that that it is a slow
process and I that this is right now
this is the trend that I'm seeing across
the entire ecosystem of web3 which is
you know the the user experience uh
potentially isn't as good as it as it as
it needs to be but you know everybody's
working together and I definitely think
that we're gonna get there because the
utility is that it's just so important
um you know to have this decentralized
information so let's talk a little bit
more about Tommy Dow because I
understand that that's really important
to um you know the the decentralization
of the entire ecosystem around the
project you guys have a very big
community and a token which provides
voting rights and decision making so how
does this work and why is this important
for the Tommy net
it's important because we don't want to
have big titles because we don't believe
that the sun is shining from our asses
right so so we need to we need to make
sure the the the the the power is really
in the ends of the people and we need to
make sure that the project is continuity
uh and this is why it was very important
to develop it in a way that some of the
team members by the way they didn't like
it some of the founders of the project
they didn't like it they say listen what
about us we developed it we whatever but
you know if you take all the power to
yourself and then you inherited to your
kids
then you're becoming the same you let
greed affect your ideology if we take
money and put it in the side and you ask
someone oh what do you think about it
now then you gives you a pure encil but
when money is involved then greed
accepting your decisions so
what we were convinced it and it wasn't
easy by the way it's not like all of us
said oh yeah it was a struggle and
that's fine but in the end
we understood that giving away the power
to the Dow will actually not only
benefit the project but also benefit us
because you know when you're too
comfortable
you're getting sloppy
you're creating less value
and where when you shout when you're
afraid the the the community the people
is judging you and they can replace you
tomorrow and then you then you are much
shelter you walk out there you create
much more value and this is how it
should be and as long as we are in
charge this is how it will be but look
at the design even if even if they
replace us the new team will have the
same mechanism it will need to be sharp
it will need to deliver the liver
deliver the level create value
so we understood that this is the right
system and if we do a good job then yes
we'll make money also but we are here
and we were fortunate because I told you
the beginning all of us are in critical
four years now so we've been extremely
fortunate and lucky
to make enough money
that will put us in a place that money
is not the main factor in decision
making
and I think it was an important factor
that made us choose this path in this
Lane
so the only way the only way the only
Democratic way the only free way
12 decision made is only by the people
and we think that the Dao is the perfect
solution for this we think that in the
Futures maybe even countries
should have this kind of systems of
decision making and not only by a demo
status you know democratos it's like
democracy dictators
I think you make a really important
point because if you um you know if
there's no way for uh team leaders to be
um held accountable then yes absolutely
they're going to be lazy and sloppy and
this essentially empowers you and forces
you to stay on top of things and make
sure that you're always working in the
interest of the community rather than um
you know yourselves but out of interest
you said that you've been in crypto for
years if you don't mind me asking I'm
just really curious what price did you
guys get in on with Bitcoin back in the
early days
yeah so so one of us got Bitcoin in like
two two plus dollars wow
yeah uh then me and and one other guy we
got in in around 20 bucks
wow and then uh we got in early on both
cardano and the ethereum okay so you
think my CEO cardano Ico
so we've been extremely fortunate and
lucky
yeah but but you know you can't just
stop walking we are we are the kind of
people that like to create value and
that we think that what we do is
extremely important so we get up in the
morning
and we jump and and we create and we
generate the value
yeah that's amazing out of interest
because I understand that creating this
alternative internet
um as we've discussed is a major
undertaking both financially and
strategically so what were some of the
biggest challenges that you're facing in
creating an alternative internet for
example have you had any issues with us
and EU regulations or any technical
challenges any societal issues like what
are the biggest struggles that you guys
face right now
yeah so so obviously you know there's
constant struggles every day
we believe that the best way to create
value is not winning a a big walls we
think that the best way to deal with
challenges is actually small wins small
wins not the big ones forget about the
big ones small ones getting up in the
morning finish this task that you don't
feel like finishing it that you want to
postpone it to tomorrow to next week
because it's you didn't figure it out
and this is like the daily mentality
that we have is to not postpone anything
do not leave anything undone just to
have this mentality of getting things
done
is a daily struggle it's a big struggle
then you know other than this mentality
a culture uh obviously the the
technology is not the simple one and the
content to get the content to get
Brands to understand wait we there's an
alternative one
there's an alternative option then this
is kind of a challenge we see right now
and then a
another big challenge is when we speak
with crypto people so that there's also
that's like a struggle that we didn't
still solve so when you sit with kids to
people
and you try to explain the importance of
what you're doing most of them seriously
most of them they only care about the
price of the token it's going up is it
going down and
though I believe I I really believe I
put a lot of my money and all of my time
in this project
when I joined it and the guy that
introduced me to this project and he's
one of the team leaders as well put
more money than mine and more time than
me in this project and those are big
people
in the crypto industry we do it because
we definitely believe that Tommy has the
potential similar to the potential we
saw in projects like ethereum and and
cardano we definitely believe that in
five years from now Tommy would be a
huge project
but
you want to be focusing on the product
and the benefits of it and the crypto
people which are jumping right over
most of them only cares about the price
then when you go and you speak about the
user with the users and with the content
creators
they some of them are afraid of crypto
because of the image of crypto so I
think
this kind of problems are the main
problems because in terms of Technology
we have an amazing team
we know how to deliver we are delivering
from the main issue is this
how to connect between the crypto
and the mainstream which is a big
problem
yeah I mean also a lot of people a lot
of people are often you know encrypted
for the wrong reasons well not to say
the wrong reasons but the reasons which
aren't you know of the same as ours so
you know some people are only here for
the for the token to pump other people
are here for decentralization other
people are here
um you know to build communities and
things like that so
everybody has you know everybody has
their own their own reasons for being
here
um but what's really interesting and we
kind of touched on this earlier is this
um difference between privacy and
anonymity and privacy is obviously a
huge issue right now and it's something
people want when browsing the web and
when transacting with money you know a
lot of people
um like I like Bitcoin a lot um but a
lot of people including myself often
don't like what you mentioned earlier
which is the fact that when you send
money people can see exactly how much
you have
um and that's a big concern for me
actually that's why a lot of people
prefer Monero over Bitcoin so can you
explain in more detail how Tommy
actually addresses privacy and Security
in its development and day-to-day
operations
yeah so so when we do it with our own
browser then we simply
use similar techniques to what Drake is
using with the cookies uh
and and protecting the data and and
obviously encrypting uh everything just
like told us so we're like combining
those two uh but when we speak about
private transactions
the issue is private transactions is not
only
the fact that you can go and see my
history and my balance it's also
authorities and governments and
sometimes exchanges even
centralized exchanges that can start to
analyze this address where he's been
where it wasn't uh what it bought what
it didn't this nft that nft there's many
many issues you know even nfts like the
fact that I can send you something to
your wallet without your agreeing to
accept it it's also an issue okay I can
send you a photos that you don't like to
receive and to be stored in your wallet
so so we think that the system is a huge
potential and it's fulfilling some of
the potential but it's not solving
everything yet it's not in the place
that the the normal Financial system out
in order to get the are not going to
expose exactly
the architecture because we want to do
an announcement with our partner on this
hopefully in around six weeks from now
we're going to announce how Tommy deals
with private transactions with a light
filter that we are writing these days
and with the amazing code that has been
written in the last six months uh with
an amazing product crypto project that
is working with a zero knowledge proof
so we leave this to that but we do
understand just like you
that this need for privacy
and this need for anonymity and privacy
is important for your freedom it's
important to control your assets because
you know Government Can can tomorrow say
okay this address is is blacklisted now
and then boom all of your assets are
kind of frozen or kind of gone because
once it's blacklisted no one will
transact with you so that's that's
that's a huge problem that's a big
governments are controlling us full of
money they are controlling us through
our money so so you need to be private
you need to be a privacy is key whether
you know we spoke we spoke before about
privacy and we spoke oh in this country
and in that country this website or that
website is blocked but listen I read
recently that in one of the countries in
America
they are blocking people that are under
from surfing in adult websites for
example okay so that's kind of crazy
it's blocked and if you want to release
it you need to actively actively send a
request
to the country with your ID and say I
want to
serve adult websites or only from The
Shane people won't do it it's completely
not the
blocking people for sure so and that's
this is in America this is in America
it's not in a it's not in China okay
it's not in Saudi Arabia it's in America
so I I think censorship
is becoming terrifying it's becoming
really really scary and if we're not
going we we can't trust a certain person
to change it we need to change the
system
the system needs to be changed
you can't be all
you know those good Kings there's bad
kings Elon Musk is a great king but he's
still a king he's a king he has the
power we don't like this system you know
CZ CZ is amazing we love CZ yeah and you
can say that Sam was a bad King maybe
maybe he was maybe he wasn't
but CeCe is a king also yes centralized
exchanges are things also we need to
have a system
that really respects the ideology of
decentralization and give the power to
the people and we are not there not only
in the mainstream world we are not there
even in the crypto industry
yeah I think it's so interesting people
often um you know turn these characters
into Kings and heroes and sort of say
you know Elon Musk is going to save the
day but I I just think you know all
humans are corruptable or power corrupt
so you know not not putting uh
everything in the power of one
centralized King is probably an
extremely smart idea
um so just lastly before we wrap this up
can you tell me what's next for Tommy
what are your future plans and what is
the long-term vision
yeah so this series is going to be very
exciting for us uh we only launched the
token and the in the test net like 40
days ago already listed in like three uh
uh meaningful exchanges uh but then the
the next steps are much more exciting
okay than the token so so next steps is
to launch the main app
uh and then there's the Privacy Law that
I spoke about at around six weeks we're
going to announce it uh which we think
is a big big uh thing for the crypto
industry and then
there's going to be also
towards the end of the year we're going
to launch
I don't know exactly when but you're
gonna see more and more Partnerships
content Partnerships as I said it before
we're going to invest tens of millions
of dollars into bringing content into
the dominant right we believe that
content is the king and that people like
yourself people that create valuable
content those are the people that makes
others consume this and interact with
and this is why and this is something
that we're going to invest a lot of
money and time
so this is also something that you
should expect this year this is the the
the the the the near future plans for
for the dominant go live be private and
bring content creators this is 2023 for
us
sounds so exciting and I totally agree
with you content is King you need to get
as much content out there as possible
um you know as they say you can build it
but you can build a project but doesn't
mean people will come you have to
actually you know get the marketing
going and you know you have to actually
make a noise and put a flag in the
ground which you guys are definitely
doing
um so techno it's been so fascinating
having you on my podcast today I want to
thank you so much for giving me all this
Insight um I really love what you're
doing I really appreciate the uh the
push for privacy anonymity
decentralization
um you know speaking up against
everything that's going on so I want to
thank you so much for coming on the show
today
thank you and I thank you for so much
for you for this stage and for this
opportunity to share Tommy with your
audience and I invite everyone I think
you know I think everyone should go to
tommy.com and do their own research it's
so early it's so so early and there's a
huge huge opportunity over here and I'm
inviting everyone to join this project
in some capacity and hopefully hopefully
together slowly step by step we'll have
a more free world in the future
absolutely and can people follow you on
social media obviously you have the
website but where else can people follow
you and stay updated
oh yeah sure so so we have Twitter from
pioneers and then you know just go to
tommy.com and over there there's the
Discord there's the telegram Tick Tock
everything is overbilled
amazing techno thank you so much for
coming on I also want to thank everybody
for watching we've had a really live um
and exciting chat which uh technically
you can check out um after we get off
this call
um everybody seems to be uh very excited
in the chat which has been fun I want to
thank you all so much for watching
please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe as we're going to
be bringing you a lot more of this kind
of content pushing free speech
decentralization and very
anti-censorship so that is all thank you
so much for watching and we will see you
all next week bye bye